in this video we're going to start
looking at something called spin spin
was something that was only discovered
when people started experimenting on
very small things like electrons I'm
going to tell you about some of the
experimental facts that they found
firstly what is it we know that normal
objects can have all kinds of measurable
properties like position speed
temperature etc spin is another one of
these properties that you can measure of
a particle and in the same way that a
particle can have different positions
and change its position the spin of an
object can take different values and
change over time but unlike these
properties it's hard to describe what it
actually is intuitively the best I can
do is say that the spin of a particle
measures how magnetic it is and decides
which direction the magnetic field is
pointing the problem with this statement
is that it makes particles seem like
they act like tiny little bar magnets
actually they don't because as we'll see
spin is a very strange thing let's just
get to those experimental facts and
we'll return to this point later from
here on in we're going to be looking at
the spin of electrons whenever we
measure spin we have to pick a direction
in other words an axis to measure it in
let's call the direction pointing east
the x axis and the direction pointing
north the y axis then say I happen to
know that an electron has spin of some
strengths that I'll call s in the X
Direction it's tempting to say that the
electron is like a bar magnet pointing
in the X direction but if that was the
case then how much spin would you expect
the electron to have in the Y direction
well the Y Direction is perpendicular to
X so normally we wouldn't expect there
to be any magnetic fields that way at
all however if you measure the spin in
the Y direction you will get a very
weird result say we do do this
experiment and record the results then
do it again using a new electron and
keep repeating
half the time you'll find that the
particle not only does have spin in that
direction its strength is still s the
other half of the time it will still
have strength s but this time in the
negative direction of y this is
completely unexpected but notice
something if we take the average of the
results we get zero which was the result
we thought we'd get hmm let's try
another example let's start with the
particle with spin s in the X direction
again we'll pick the 45-degree access to
measure the spin in what would we
normally expect
well the 45 degree angle axis is still
somewhat pointing in the X direction so
we'd expect that there is some spin in
that direction but a smaller amount than
s we can calculate how strong we think
it should be using vectors and get that
the new spin should be s on route 2 but
what happens when we measure it again
every single time we repeat this
experiment the electron will have spin
of strength s but this time it will be
slightly more likely to have it in the
positive direction than the negative so
that when we take the average of all the
results we get s on route 2 again though
each individual trial was unexpected the
average result is what we thought we'd
get let me summarize the two things we
can learn about the spin of an electron
from these kind of experiments firstly
no matter what direction we pick to
measure the spin in it's value will
always be positive s or negative s where
s is equal to this small number will
give these two possibilities some
convenient names up and down so you can
for example say that an electron is spin
down in the Y direction the second weird
thing is that wherever you'd normally
expect an electron to have a certain
spin in a direction let's say spin equal
decay you will instead find that each
time you measure you will only get spin
up or spin down but when you average the
spin of each trial you get the right
result
ie averaging your data will give you
okay so you see it's possible to say
which direction and electron spin is in
and its strengths but it's not really
like the classical situation with a bar
magnet with a bar magnet knowing how
strong the magnet is and in what
direction allows you to find its
strength in all other directions that's
not the case with spin when there's lots
of particles will spin on average they
act just like bar magnets in fact that's
what a bar magnet is it's heaps of
particles with spin stuck together but
individually these particles act like
they are equally strong in all
directions that they're measured in and
act randomly we still don't know if this
randomness is true randomness though and
we still don't know what spin really is